une femme aurait besoin d'au moins une
heure pour se préparer
17 minutes pour la douche 21 pour les
soins
quinze pour l'essayage et 12 pour le
maquillage rassurer les hommes nous ont
fait beaucoup moins sept minutes pour le
rasage deux minutes pour s'habiller et
le reste du temps à attendre notre
métier
savez vous que la beauté ça demande un
peu d'effort ce n'est pas une question
de choix mais un style de vie
ce n'est pas un acte ponctuel mais un
acte au quotidien
et si on se posait cette question qui
peut prétendre avoir la beauté absolue
personne en effet à part notre ami notre
ami là-bas et adam
mais permettez moi de vous dire qu'on
est tous moches mais attention je parle
pas de vous il de vous derrière ni de
vous mais je parle de notre image
collective celle de la tunisie
nous sommes moche
si on aime bien être bien présentable
paraître bon alors pourquoi ne pas le
faire pour notre propre pays
par exemple cet immeuble à tunis ancien
si on lui donnait un nouvel
vignes par exemple une nouvelle couche
de peinture au niveau de la rue l on va
la changer on va la rendre piétonne on
va l'élargir et au niveau des vitrines
on va essayer de standardiser le tout
ici à la fin ils viennent ils nous
disent mais vous avez explosé le budget
ou bien que vous êtes un peu un peu
rêveur ben on va rajouter une voiture
volante ou bien cette marque qui est
typiquement représentatif de cette
tunisie piquante leiris tout le monde
connaît un packaging que tout le monde
connaît aussi et qui datent énormément
et si on lui donnait une un côté un peu
plus esthétique par exemple ça peut être
ça
ou bien une marque que j'aime bien mais
qui est plus orientée dans une optique
100 % produits avec que du le du ludique
si on lui donnait un volet un peu plus
conceptuel
un peu de fraîcheur enivrant bien
ça pourrait donner sa en tant que
designer graphique
j'ai remarqué qu'en tunisie on a un
manque de conscience graphique
pire encore
nous n'avons pas de culture graphique
malgré que ce même pays
il regorge d'histoires d' aventure et il
a même une identité nationale forte
certes complexe mais vous avez la
tunisie est un pays assez spéciaux
autour de moi j'entends toujours parler
de management de de marketing de
stratégie de business mais en parle
moins de design graphique d'image de
marque d'esthétique ou de graphie et
bien pour cela j'ai lancé graphique à
elle
avant la culture se résumer à quelques
événements quelques expositions ont
parlé de photographies d'art plastique
de théâtre de musique sans pour autant
avoir un regard plus ouverts à d'autres
disciplines
qui sont autant plus autant plus
importante
et bien notre plateforme s'est mis comme
but de mettre en avant ces artistes tous
et créative et de leur dire que il ya
une plateforme qui concluront
vous allez me dire que de plus en plus
il ya énormément de plateformes qui qui
existe qui parle d'art qui parle
d'artistes aussi nous notre différence
c'est que nous on relaie pas de
l'information nous sommes créateurs de
valeur
un des exemples de créatifs d'artistes
tunisiens qui qui était peu connu mais
qui sont qui ont évolué
et puis pourquoi pas au fur et à mesure
on va changer les choses par comme ça
par exemple on a un version ancienne
d'une d'un timbre avec en face une
version plus moderne par exemple
et si on arrivait à changer les panneaux
de signalisation des panneaux qui sont
plus ludiques ou qui sont plus
technologique jusqu'à arriver même à
changer notre propre carte d'identité
dans la salle certainement il ya des
entrepreneurs des futurs entrepreneurs
des managers des marketeurs de braine
manager
eh bien il ya une solution qui peut être
applicable pourquoi ne pas intégrer un
créatif on invente du processus
stratégiques
cela vous pourrez pourrait vous donner
un impact beaucoup plus important non
seulement au niveau financier mais aussi
au niveau image
et puis pour finir j'aimerais vous dire
no more by globo
identique